What is the difference between an allergy to food and a sensitivity food? I think they're saying you so
It's really a matter of semantics to a degree. So
typically a food sensitivity
It has to do with the different of mutiliglobulins that are
Firing that's a part of your immune response
um when you talk about a like a peanut allergy that's a that's an i g g that's an i g e reaction
And that is a more of an immediate immune response that could cause hyper inflammation and even lead to death
Because the hair the person's airways can be blocked
But we're talking typically about a food sensitivity. We're talking about a
A delayed response an i g g response and that is um or of a delayed response
So food sensitivity to gluten let's say you have i g g antibodies to gluten
um
That's not the same as full celiac disease. Well the person with celiac disease is exposed to gluten
Can get such severe pain in their abdominal
Area that they could end up in the ER and uh, you know could have you know quite a lot of damage to their intestinal tract
Versus somebody with an i g g reaction to
Gluten will have a ramped up inflammation that could be just as damaging
um
Systemically, but not as damaging specifically to the gut wall
And something like an acute reaction like that. So that's really the difference
But for most people it's more syventic so when you go when you say i like um
You're at a restaurant is this gluten-free now they say is this an allergy or sensitivity the reason is that if you have
celiac disease
They're not going to serve you anything because their kitchen isn't a pure celiac um gluten
um
Clean
Kitchen they have other products in there that have gluten in it. It may be your food is going to be served with um
You know gluten-free bread, but there's no guarantee that it's that you know something else wasn't fried of that same
Grittle that had bread, you know that has gluten on it
So you could still have a reaction if you had a celiac disease
So if you do have
full celiac or i g e
peanut allergy you have to be far more careful getting around somebody with peanuts
Some people with celiac can't even walk
Can't even go grocery shopping because they can't go in the bakery section because breathing in that
um
The
Gliann that may be
floating in the air could cause a reaction and cause issues
So that's really the difference. So you should say if you have you did a cirex 3
4 and 10 that you show different food allergies
um
Technically their food sense tibities. I mean technically you do have an allergy you have antibodies to that thing and it is serious
Um, but it's
It's typically not immediately life-threatening that's really